Ich habe Sie gebeten, sich vorzustellen, dass Sie
in einem Park spazieren gehen und an einem
flachen Teich vorbeikommen und feststellen, dass ein kleines
Kind in den Teich gefallen ist und
zu ertrinken droht.
Was würden Sie also wahrscheinlich tun?  Sieh dich um, um zu
sehen, ob die Eltern des Kindes da sind, aber
wenn nicht, würdest du in den
Teich springen und das Kind retten, und das würdest du tun
, selbst wenn du teure
Kleidung und teure Schuhe trägst, die du
so ruinieren wirst  Ich denke, das zeigt,
dass es nicht ausreicht, Menschen keinen Schaden zuzufügen
, also gibt es Umstände,
unter denen man
etwas wirklich Schlimmes getan hat, wenn man kein Leben rettet,
und ähnlich denke ich, wenn man
Menschen dabei hilft  Entwicklungsländern, wo wir
wissen, dass Kinder sterben,
weil sie keine grundlegende
Gesundheitsversorgung oder sauberes Trinkwasser oder
ähnliches bekommen, und wir wissen, dass
wir ihnen durch effektive Wohltätigkeitsorganisationen helfen können, ist
es auch schlecht, wenn Sie
ignoriere das einfach wenn  Sie leben einfach
Ihr bequemes Leben und tun
nichts, um zur Rettung anderer beizutragen,
dann denke ich, dass das zeigt, dass Sie kein
ethisches Leben führen